[Musica]
cosa vuol dire essere un giovane card
giver quando una persona cara inizia a
star male
la tensione è tutta su quella persona
sui suoi bisogni ma se quella persona
che sa qualcosa che non va e tua mamma 8
papà cosa accade
cosa accade a tezze quando mamma o papà
o entrambi inizia la star male se è
ancora un bambino o un adolescente
quando ero un adolescente non avevo la
più pallida idea di essere una giovane
caregiver come tutti andavo a scuola
ride voi scherzavo con gli amici ma cosa
c'è dietro a queste foto che non si vede
prima di raccontarvi la parte nascosta
dell'iceberg
vorrei fare un passo indietro e
ricominciare sempre dal principio se vi
chiedesse cosa è cambiato e cosa è
rimasto uguale probabilmente a partire
da me dire se che amo ancora i cani e ho
cambiato tagli di capelli
ma cosa c'è di invisibile in quelle foto
che cosa mi ha portato dalla mia bambina
che vedete al centro alla mia adulta che
sono oggi passando per la mia
adolescente che vedete a sinistra un
certo punto uno tsunami ha investito la
mia famiglia
uno tsunami che ha cresciuto
progressivamente fino a poi a
travolgerla uno tsunami chiamato
problema di salute e quando colpisce 1
entrambi i tuoi genitori e tu sei ancora
un bambino un adolescente loro sono i
tuoi punti di riferimento diventa
davvero complicato
e se vi dicessi che il problema di
salute è un problema di salute mentale
il carico per un figlio può essere molto
pesante e può essere fatto di sensi di
colpa paura rabbia tristezza amore odio
che si alternano vorticosamente la
sensazione costante di camminare sulle
uova un carico eccessivo di
responsabilità
la difficoltà a concentrarsi e anche il
doversi occupare di faccende domestiche
come fare la spesa o badare a fedeli ne
sono linee più piccole o parlare con i
medici gestire la terapia oppure essere
vittima di bullismo
magari a causa dei comportamenti
bizzarri che il tuo genitore potrebbe
avere ma in aggiunta a questo potreste
dover gestire delle vere e proprie
emergenze per le quali nessuno ti ha
preparato come gestire la situazione
mentre tuo padre e tua madre vede tante
cose che non esistono le psicosi o dover
avere a che fare con l'alternarsi di
stati in maniacali e depressivi senza
che nessuno ti abbia preparato a farlo o
addirittura assistero sventare i
tentativi di suicidio ma in aggiunta a
tutto questo
dovendo poi continuare anche a fare la
vita di sempre andare a scuola a
studiare il motivo per cui sono qui oggi
è che si aggiunge un altro carico che è
spesso non poterne parlare con nessuno
16 che tua mamma 8 papa ma un problema
di salute fisica un tumore un'altra
patologia fisica difficilmente qualcuno
li colpevolizza era per questo ho le
riterrà dei cattivi genitori o delle
persone deboli difficilmente qualcuno
considerate come geneticamente
compromesso e destinato in automatico a
ereditare lo stesso disturbo ma se provi
a dire che tua mamma tuo papà hanno una
depressione maggiore un disturbo
bipolare una schizofrenia o se non c'è
neanche una diagnosi a descrivere il
loro comportamento e dire mamma papà
hanno qualcosa che non va
la risposta del mondo esterno sarà
completamente diversa ancora oggi in
tutto il mondo la salute fisica la
salute mentale non godono della stessa
dignità e rispetto
ancora oggi non è percepita con un bene
comune che appartiene a tutti noi e
questo comporta un ritardo nel capire
cosa accade dentro di sé e ai propri
cari
un ritardo a chiedere e ricevere aiuto
spesso non ricevere ha fatto una cura e
per te che sei figlio il carico diventa
ancora più pesante il clima che
percepisci intorno a te la difficoltà
con
unica re dentro e fuori la famiglia lo
stigma il pregiudizio alla vergogna
possono portarti a tenerti tutto dentro
e non dire proprio niente
ma la solitudine e il silenzio sono un
carico pesante da portare per un minore
come facevo io ad affrontare la
situazione cosa c'è dietro quelle foto
che non è visibile dietro a quel sorriso
c'era una corazza che si è venuta a
formare in automatico dietro la quale
nascondevo una corazza di ghiaccio che
mi permetteva di tender dentro paura
rabbia e dolore ed evitare che
travolgessero me le persone che avevo
intorno mi permetteva di continuare a
fare le cose di tutti i miei coetanei ma
che allo stesso tempo mi faceva sentire
distante anni luce da loro perché mi
faceva mi aveva fatto crescere prima
degli altri
allo stesso tempo c'era anche un grido
di aiuto un rilievo che non poteva che
non riusciva a uscire che nessuno
neanche a scuola immaginava quando la
prima crepa ha iniziato ad aprirsi in
quella corazza quando la prima volta la
luce ha iniziato a filtrare ricordo
ancora con affetto la psicologa del
consultorio familiare che alla prima
persona fidata della famiglia con la
quale ho potuto aprirmi e che mi ha
aiutato piano piano a individuare
persone fidate intorno a me la rete
estesa che potessero essermi di supporto
ma il vero e proprio spartiacque è stato
per me
l'aver letto in internet su dei forum le
storie di altri figli di altri paesi
grazie all'amore per le lingue che mi
avevano trasmesso i miei genitori
le storie di noi figli i genitori con
disturbo mentale sono tutte diverse
tutte uniche ma c'è una cosa che mi ha
colpito è che abbiamo in comune e che
spesso siamo convinti di essere gli
unici ma è statisticamente impossibile
nel mondo siamo milioni di persone
eppure ci convinciamo di esserlo che non
ci sia nessun altro che abbia vissuto le
stesse cose che abbiamo vissuto noi
e sapete perché accade perché delle
nostre storie di figli non parliamo
attraverso le storie di figli attivisti
provenienti da australia affati uniti il
canada
non solo ho potuto dare un nome a delle
mozioni che avevo provato e capire che
erano naturale reazione a quello che
avevo vissuto ma potuto anche vedere le
caratteristiche positive erano nate
proprio per far fronte a quella
situazione e quindi ho preso il mio
primo volo intercontinentale da sola ne
sono andata a vancouver in canada per la
prima conferenza in cui ho parlato per
incontrarli questi figli per parlare con
loro ed è stato un momento di specchia
mento positivo potentissimo perché i
loro visto la storia che avevo vissuto
ma anche quella ancora da scrivere i
loro visto il dolore ma anche la
capacità di riscatto di trasformare quel
dolore insegne per un cambiamento
ho visto quelle caratteristiche positive
di resilienza empatia coraggio volontà
di cambiare lo status quo che non
riconoscevo in me ma che vedendo le
riflesse in loro finalmente sentito
anche mie quell'incontro è stato un dono
immenso che mi dà energia ancora adesso
ed è un dono che io ho voluto fortemente
riportare in italia in europa per
aiutare altri forgotten children altri
figli dimenticati a poter togliere dei
pesi dalle loro spalle
il desiderio è che nessun bambino
adolescente giovane adulto debba più
sentirsi solo quando uno o entrambi i
genitori iniziano a soffrire di un
disturbo psico è un desiderio immenso
che ha bisogno dell'aiuto di tutti
perché altrimenti come non rischiare
ancora una volta di caricare il peso del
mondo tutto sulle mie spalle
ed è così che arriviamo ad oggi nel 2017
insieme ad altri figli italiani
gaia carlo e marco abbiamo fatto nascere
la prima associazione italiana creata da
figli per altri figli per dare voce a
bambini adolescenti che non hanno una
voce per far valere le nostre istanze
anche alle istituzioni e si chiama comic
children of men tallinn parens fili
genitori con disturbo mentale abbiamo
dato il via a un progetto che si chiama
come la mini guida che ho scritto che
avrei voluto avere fra le mani io quando
avevo 15 anni si chiama quando mamma o
papà hanno qualcosa che non va mini
guida la sopravvivenza per figli di
genitori con disturbo mentale
ed è un progetto che è partito dal basso
grazie al cra utv anni grazie all'aiuto
di persone vicine a me alcune sono qui
in questa sala adesso che hanno creduto
in questo stesso desiderio ci hanno dato
linfa per farlo partire e farlo svettare
alto questo progetto ha l'obiettivo
ambizioso di donare una copia di questa
mini guida a tutte le biblioteche
scolastiche cittadine a tutti i
consultori centri fondamentali d'italia
perché nessun ragazzo si ha più lasciato
solo e neanche le loro famiglie
soprattutto i figli di genitori che non
sono consapevoli del loro disturbo e non
sono neanche in cura per il loro
disturbo noi anche questi ragazzi
dobbiamo pensare io sono stata una di
loro per un periodo
all'inizio quando ho pensato questo
progetto mi sono detta non ce la farò
mai realizzarlo come farò piano piano
però ho chiesto aiuto alle persone
intorno a me anche alle guide
escursioniste proponendo di raccontare
durante una passeggiata in dieci minuti
la storia e trovare così e persone della
società civile che magari non hanno
vissuto questa esperienza che sono
voluti diventare i nostri posti nel
cambiamento e portare una copia della
mini guida in dono da parte nostra alla
biblioteca del loro comune e adesso
siamo riusciti ad arrivare in tantissime
regioni dalla val d'aosta fino alla
sicilia la sardegna non ci fermiamo
vogliamo raggiungere le tutte un altro
desiderio che abbiamo è quello appunto
di smuovere le istituzioni a fare di più
per noi ma anche la società civile e
investire di più in salute mentale e
l'altro desiderio enorme che stiamo
realizzando e quello di incontrare le
scuole parlare con gli studenti con i
ragazzi non soltanto i figli caregiver
ma tutti per poter avere una cassetta
degli attrezzi per fare fronte a quelle
che sono le emozioni positive e negative
le sfide della vita partendo attrezzati
prima che si sia troppo male per salvare
le vite è un cammino lungo e tortuoso
quello che abbiamo davanti
ma se c'è una cosa che so è che una
delle caratteristiche positive che noi
figli di genitori con disturbo mentale
abbiamo e la volontà di cambiare lo
status quo ed è per questo
so che quella ragazza ce la farà a
realizzare il suo desiderio anche grazie
a voi se questa storia è colpito e ha
emozionato
parlatene raccontate dai vostri amici ai
colleghi
apriamo insieme quella porticina che per
noi non si era aperta
facciamo entrare la luce grazie
[Applauso]